anne trouve le cadeau parfait sur le
site internet d'un grand détaillant en
ben ali par le petit prix rassuré par la
grande bannière elle l'achète en un clic
mais à la réception grande déception au
nom elle trouve que le jouet de mauvaise
qualité et qui ne vaut pas le prix payé
pas grave se dit anne ok je le retourne
illico
mais surprise ça ne se passe pas comme
d'habitude
cette fois ci elle ne peut pas
simplement retourner le produit sans
frais de possibles pour avoir ce
remboursement
on doit d'abord retourné je jouais à ses
frais pourquoi parce que même si elle a
fait son achat sur le site du grand
détaillant elle l'a acheté d'un vendeur
indépendant
c'est ce qu'on appelle un vendeur tiers
un fournisseur hébergé pour les tailles
en mai qui vend sa propre marchandises
et surtout qui a sa propre politique de
retour et on découvre kelly moins
avantageuses c'était d'ailleurs indiqué
dans les conditions de vente
mais dans son empressement à ne l'avait
pas remarqué le fin mot de l'histoire
sur internet sachez reconnaître un
vendeur tiers avant de lui donner le feu
vert